sommer am bodensee die bregenzer
festspiele haben begonnen
in diesem jahr steht die zauberflöte auf
dem spielplan das werk von wolfgang
amadeus mozart ist eine der
meistgespielten opern der welt
einen monat lang werden nun fast jeden
abend 7000 besucher in die bregenzer
arena kommen die saison ist ausverkauft
seit 2003 ist der brite david pountney
intendant der bregenzer festspiele er
führte bei der zauberflöte auch regie
die grundidee ist dass wir haben so ein
primitives welt gebaut das ist eine
insel sowie man findet in ein alters
karte wo man nicht gewusst hat was dort
eigentlich war und man hat so eine
fantasie insel gezeichnet mit seltsamen
tieren und und und monsters und so
weiter
die zauberflöte als archiv fantastische
märchenwelt nicht nur das bühnenbild
auch die kostüme folgen dieser idee
der nun kann sich nicht frei genug
bewegen die puppen und kostüme hat
marie-jeanne lecca entworfen
wir werden es hier abschneiden und auch
hier da an dieser stelle stört das
stimmt
seit 1999 hat marie jeanne lecca immer
wieder als kostümbildnerin für die
bregenzer festspiele gearbeitet
das ist kein leichtes stück und es ist
natürlich eine herausforderung so etwas
auf einer seebühne zu machen gerade
heute morgen kam es nie denn wir sind
die zauberflöte ist ein bisschen wie
shakespeare um es mal kritisch zu sehen
die oper ist so bekannt jedem ist sie
vertraut
papageno der vogelfänger ist eine der
hauptfiguren der oper
das ist eines meiner lieblings christina
marie jeanne lecca ist gebürtige rumänin
und lebt in london die international
viel beschäftigte kostümbildnerin hat
schon für das bolschoi theater in moskau
für die salzburger festspiele oder die
wiener staatsoper gearbeitet
dann euch eine gute chance dass alles
gut läuft
technisch gesehen muss man zunächst
beachten dass ich alles unter freiem
himmel abspielt es kann regnen dann der
wind alles muss widerstandsfähig sein
für die vogelfiguren zum beispiel haben
wir auch net stoffe genommen damit der
wind durch gehen kann und sie nicht vom
wind weggetragen werden all das muss man
berücksichtigen
letzte kontrolle in der garderobe einer
weiteren hauptfigur der zauberflöte in
einem von mehreren kostümen die königin
der nacht
zudem bilde wahnsinn
von der technik her
imposant
ganz ganz toll also die sängerische
leistung und aber auch die gestaltung
der bühne einfach super zauberhaft
das schlussduett von papageno und
papagena
für jene die keine karten bekommen
konnten gibt es hoffnung die zauberflöte
wird auf der bregenzer seebühne auch
2014 gespielt